what up reject nation we're gonna watch
today brooklyn benign something episode
it's in the title learn to read guys
full length watch along as we sing up
with the time code over at patreon.com
the real rejects catch our full-length
watchalongs and other shows that we
cover over there with reaction
highlights exclusives for super sexy
rejects if you don't want to do that and
be selfish at least leave a like that
would be very much appreciated and while
you're at it subscribe and click that
notification bell we're only going to
watch two more episodes of this we
decided it's a good point to stop it
let's see how people feel when i say
that this is a funny little social
experiment and thanks to the boys and
prep for helping us out these down
john are you ready i'm
ready
[Music]
a new vending machine
behold him in all of his glory so full
of strength and promise and most
importantly sodium gluten and fat
boil the champagne well technically it's
a hungarian pesco from the tarnock
valley for once in your life don't ruin
it give them a bottle
oh this is exactly what i was hoping for
snacky chan
yes
yes
okay well at least it was just the
keypad none of the snacks got messed up
no
it's okay now those core nuts will be
toasted let's get pattern oswald back
watch my prediction come true our perp's
name is carl ovay i see i said he's
selling counterfeit caviar out of a blue
stall this place smells like a squid
farted inside a whale's butt
hey next week is my six month
anniversary with amy should i do
something special you know what i like
about our relationship jake we don't
talk about our love lives or our
families or anything that's on our minds
it's why you're my closest friend of the
world yeah i know but i need help on
this i asked boyle and he was useless
put a baby in her jake
so do that then problem solved
look it's okay i forget him and amy are
dating excuse me sir we're with the nypd
i just need to ask you a couple
shrimp i hate that bubba gum
what have we here dear schusterman what
do you s i have no idea what you're
saying dear shoot bola diamond just as i
suspected immediately
i've just received word from interpol
that two detectives are on their way
from sweden to pick up the suspect
please make them feel welcome oh no
guest stars
so we there's detectives do you guys
know anyone who wants some used
textbooks i'd love them it's never too
late to teach yourself something so no
one great oh
why are you throwing those out because
i'm never gonna pass this astronomy
final so i won't graduate so my life is
ruined astronomy is harder than it
sounds terry killed it in college plus i
know a thing or two about astronomy i
had 11 straight birthdays at the
planetarium that was also a brag was it
to me it is this is inspector canal's
gourd and deputy inspector connoisseur i
don't know these people it's been a
pleasure talking with you about the
duration of your flight good day ricky
lindholm we also speak norwegian dutch
german french russian and finnish but
not danish that is a garbage language
for garbage people yeah
almost memorized gangnam style
phonetically so samesies i don't know
this word samesies from context i
believe it means probably uneducated
also none foreign she and her husband
are trying to have another baby so she
can't eat anything that will alter her
cervical ph
oh good good considerations we have no
secrets not even our bodies we saw
united together all the time yeah well
we are also very close one time rosa saw
me in my bathing suit and you told me to
turn around
could you please check if our prison has
been processed yeah we don't mean to
offend it's just this place is filthy
and you both seem unprofessional oh my
god kevin has accepted a fellowship to
teach at the sobond for the next six
months oh i love paris at least how it's
represented in the movie ratatouille
the rodent chef ah yes far-fetched
rakikuni
park slope racket club where we've
established a squash doubles dynasty i
remember you told me you played in
college three-time intramural champion
at sarah lawrence would have been four
but senior year i played grease ball in
our school's production of starlight
express interesting casting
could make it a trouble absolutely i
would love to do that great
yep that is great oh my god he's
terrible why squash brings out my
competitive side of breaking rackets
cursing excessive mooning ray sislers i
locked eyes with him and ate a squash
ball that's not possible it's still in
me terry
oh my do you know what i'm allergic to
yup them totally and also bees you
should know that if i got stung by a bee
i could die detectives i've been talking
with the inspectors there's been a
development in the bula diamond case
excellent pronunciation captain doc
thank you for the tip have a wonderful
flight home we will send you the jewels
as soon as we find them they're staying
and working the case with you
ah
fantastic rosa could you please fill my
car with a million bees oh oh wow
don't kill yourself wow how about i get
to jump on our new partners and search
the perps apartment right we'll get some
clues solve the case make them look like
fools they can eat our american dust no
no sauron is probably allergic to dust
oh hello
yes i am allergic to dusk
what are you guys doing here oh in
sweden we call it police work perhaps
you don't have a word for it
can't work it without us get your weird
hairless fingers off of it suddenly
shaves his fingers for cycling it cuts
down on drag egg nature's my biggest
fanatic just as i'm a fanatic of her
slam poetry
slam we've already searched the entire
apartment yeah well now we're gonna
search it and find things you all missed
like this
your own keys damn straight back him
diaz
a parsec is actually a measure of
distance
one of the many inaccuracies in the star
wars universe oh there are known
actresses jupiter is a gas giant so is
hitchcock how does this help me it also
has 67 moons i came up with a fun
mnemonic device to remember them all it
goes every individual gets crayons after
telling
tiny panda head
period
[Laughter]
elephant into california except
uh
where's gina she told me you called me a
gas giant well now you and i will never
hook up
wow i wonder if i set out amy i wonder
if that mnemonic device was all the
moons for real nature found an
invitation to a party tonight
at the home of
oliver gustafsson the hot blonde guy
from true blood no no
there were ties to organized crime alva
gustavson oh that albergue is everything
dyched up no why do i seem psyched cause
i'm definitely not i just want to have
fun and to win hey if we all have fun
and don't throw any racquets and don't
eat squash balls then we're all winners
what nothing i'll serve don't blow this
man nah at least the beast boyle
ow what are you out of your mind that
was
[Laughter]
i know astronomy can seem a little
daunting and scientific but i have a
friend who i think can make it pretty
interesting
oh whoa oh
neil hey gene i'm neil degrass tyson and
i care why director of the hayden
planetarium one of the world's leading
astrophysicists and he's doing me a huge
favor and how do you know terence space
tie we're gym buddies
damn neil degrasse tyson how are you
doing that
physics terry
it's physics
[Laughter]
why did you want to take astronomy
because i thought it would be cool just
me sitting around naming moons left and
right like zorp
bong let's go marcus and i broke up what
when a month ago a month ago
how do i not know about this cause we
don't talk about that crap we're not
lame with the swedes right
yeah totally
totally we are about to uncover a
buttload of diamonds exactly
it's fish
it's fish rosa
dig deeper it could be in there still if
you broke up with your husband would you
tell sauron about it are you making a
funny laugh joke right now i would
insist he'd be there for it that my
husband would have a children to cry on
why do you smell like fish is it hygiene
no we spent the night cutting open
hundreds of dogfish to see if they had
diamonds inside they didn't although one
did have a battery in it what kind of a
sicko feeds a battery to a fish that's a
clue i rescheduled your cycling practice
for 16 november and your dentist for 19
november you know me so well
oh my goodness that could be you guys
we thought the shipping container came
in on october 11th 10 11. but dumb
europeans write their dates backwards
good call is everything okay you know
with your brain
[Laughter]
i had a nickel for every time i got that
question do you know why
i chose you as my partner because i'm
the most athletic person you know no
because of an article i read in the
sarah lawrence phoenix about a young man
they called
squash's unhinged lunatic
i need him on my team
i need you to
unleash
the bees
let's go boys
[Music]
we were trying to get you to learn using
our methods we should have been speaking
your language beyonce
yes now amy back up till you feel the
wall and terry ditch the shirt i'm ready
to learn
and that's how you calculate parallax
distance
you ready for the test oh i took it this
morning i passed and why'd you make us
do that whole dance
two reasons
uno
and des
i get that
one two one two one two nice
uh someday someday i guess we are the
better team
why do people like these things they're
just shiny rocks yeah yeah hold hands
we're supposed to be friends sound like
sauron or agnetta whichever the boy one
is
we're adults now and there are other
things like me and amy and you and
marcus that friends are supposed to talk
about well i guess we're not friends
then
wow all right i guess we're not
oh no no
we're moving no really thank you for
sharing that intimate detail
blergan
come on is that you i haven't seen you
since blorgenbergen man
jeez
it's me gler
nypd drop it drop it you're under arrest
i hope they have saunas in swedish
prison
they do actually they're quite nice
[Laughter]
magnifique the treble is ours i look
forward to getting number four next year
uh actually we've been banned for life
kevin i snapped the second place trophy
over my knee and threw it in a urinal oh
my yeah
but the important thing is
we had fun
yeah
back to sweden tomorrow yeah guess you
were wrong about us huh bet you feel
pretty stupid actually when you're wrong
that means you've learned something
[Laughter]
nice job today
i guess we didn't have to know each
other to have each other's backs
so drink in silence
this sucks
we saw the case and told the swedes how
to die i should be happy but
and i thought of what you should do with
amy for your anniversary oh thank god i
got her a boogie board it has an iguana
playing electric guitar on it she's
gonna hate it
so cool wait how do i become a library
vip i forgot to return super fudge in
the fourth grade and i've been scared to
go back ever since don't worry about it
i can hook you up what
my new boyfriend works there oh
i don't want to push too hard no that's
cool
i want to tell you his name
well okay it's gonna take a quick drink
break
here comes the name nope uno mas
all ready
it's tom
i love it
bonding
opening up
guys brooklyn nine-nine did it again it
was funny they had investigative stuff
there were comedic hijinks all around
learned uh had a good heart to it
learned some good life lessons we did it
we did everything all over again tune in
next week where they do all that all
over again john what did you think be
pacific oh hey uh it was cool to have
ricky lindholm of garfunkel and oats and
uh anders home from the workaholics uh
guest star i think workaholics on this
episode uh cool because weren't real
swedish people they are not
swedes but the accent was so believable
i know and they both matched each
other's accents perfectly
i'm half italian half swedish oh so i
can recognize a good swedish accent i
mean day of the week yeah yeah and i
really thought that was a swedish accent
well that's good so is this an accurate
portrayal of swedish people yeah down to
the letter this is like a good
instructional video if you're gonna go
visit sweden you should probably watch
this you know so they're all creepily
intimate yeah yeah very open very sort
of natural and uh yeah unencumbered
uninhibited that's disgusting that's
gross man how am i american what's those
walls up handshakes all around fist
bumps me too yeah
or just that awkward kind of like
you know kind of wave thing yeah yeah
well good they were funny they were i
enjoyed their chemistry they had good
chemistry indeed john what i thought was
funny was how they i like people who
don't really understand sarcasm and they
take everything literally it's a great
form of comedy
yes it is and there was lots of that
happen lots of comedy this episode lots
of uh good missed uh sarcasm moments of
andy being a bit i should say jake being
a [ __ ] why'd you say andy because uh
you know i was breaking through the
artifice thinking about andy sandberg
when really i should have been seeing
jake peralta you know the the person
yeah yeah roll on screen the actor very
good son this isn't brechtian or
anything like that this is all about
immersion very good i want to break the
immersion very good also too i mean like
hella plot lines in this episode
bunch of plot lines not only did you
have those two you had neil dad ass
tyson joined the show great joe broken
guest don't even get me started on how
great of a joe rogan guests yeah joseph
grass tyson is but i'm good it's cool to
see him cameo astronomy is harder than
it sounds on paper i don't know sun moon
all you got nothing that's right that's
right what do we need to concern
ourselves with the rest of the solar
system what does it matter to us plus i
got a mnemonic device for those it's
suck my
perfect you remember sun moon
mnemonic device or any demonic devices
two planets because what if you forget
one of the two you get a 50 50 shot
nah you can't guess two sons you need to
take an iq test i should do that
i did one really it said i'm smarter
than average really paid five hundred
dollars worth did you wow that must it
must be legitimate then all right yeah i
can't trust those free ideas
wow 500 bucks for 10 minutes yeah i got
a little email that was quick smarter
than you just yeah dude that's great oh
my goodness is there more can you like
you know spend two thousand dollars so
far yeah i was gonna say can you just
like retake the test and see if your iq
goes up yeah yeah oh man i also googled
the answers because it was online oh
cool yeah cool cool
somewhere in my inbox dude that means
that you have the same iq as the entire
internet
just the the the the utility organism
that is the internet
is it an organism it's sort of an organ
you know it grows and expands and is
alive in its own way it's not sentient
is it it's up for debate it's up for
debate
good dancing in this episode that's not
up for debate
uh
and hey holton and friggin uh you know
boyle getting all crazy with the
racquetball yeah squash ball this is
about partnerships
learning to partner up and and be
different and accept your your your
weirdness
weird stuff
yeah not hide yeah not hide yourself not
my partner i would sin boyle's was a
rage-a-holic
and um
rosa is
attracted to jake
i don't believe men and women can be
friends it's not surely sexual all the
time always having sex always doing
the dirty
bring on those trustees can't trust guys
and girls to be friends name one time
you've ever seen it successfully work
once
once
and these two don't count the swedes
don't count inevitably they will do
something they will inevitable
but they'll consider its meaning
differently than we would
but it would be the same thing
i'd like to go to sweden yeah it'd be
fun are they that open i think so plus
there would be probably a lot of saunas
around i know you love a good sauna i do
love a good sauna i paid 500 for one
dude that's a steal yeah just to sit in
one or you got the sauna itself
installed i got the sauna installed
that's a steal i still figure out how to
turn it on
it's been two years
but it's only 500 bucks dude what a
great man i know i bought six of them
don't even have to turn it on 3 000
on six cents for six saunas yeah you
could just sit there and think about how
much money you saved and work up a sweat
that way yeah yeah if i keep the door
closed long enough in the backyard
during summer during summer it works
like a gem yeah like it'll just sweat it
all out you know go inside pee all over
the rocks you know your sauna rocks and
just create that steam
the astronomy angle was weird
yeah this was a jam-packed episode or it
felt kind of jam-packed didn't really
fit
yeah it was kind of a funny side quest
that yeah
and it didn't quite even
like terry and amy have to partner up a
little bit but there's not really like
as much compliment to the overall theme
in their plot line other i feel like
jake and amy don't date
i know ever since i became boyfriend and
girlfriend like the show's like keep
them separate as much as possible i feel
like
yeah and i feel like part of it is maybe
it's
being at odds with the idea of like we
can't just do like a jake and amy date
episode that has no police context
whatsoever but then again maybe you
could i forget that they're dating i do
there's been like one episode of them
like oh they have to work together on a
case
i feel like that's how every
relationship that's not holding kevin is
gonna
be
professional uh is that yeah we don't
see them much like remember marcus bless
you thank you
i never saw mark that'll be 500
please yeah i always have 500.
i get all my withdrawals at 500 dollars
because that's what i pay
got one rate for everything in my life
but yes yes uh
something there something we were
talking about that amy and jake don't
they don't really date yeah i think they
had the network worry of you know the
will they won't they is what keeps it
exciting and then what when they do they
what i mean when they when when they
they
become they
then they're like oh no it stops being
exciting
so let's keep them separated to not ruin
it create tension since we didn't drag
this out to like season five
shakes worried about it yeah season
eight we'll finally see them go on a
date the office and and uh friends made
that work really well with chandler and
monica and and jim and pam they made the
you know because it's the what they want
there's the exciting part and then when
they got together it didn't ruin it it
got better dude that's what they need to
do here
just bring jim and pam into the show
amen sister amy and
say
jack
how many episodes we're gonna have about
rosa not opening up uh every rosa
centric episode will have something to
do with her not opening up
and uh finally getting to a point where
she opens up a little bit but very end i
mean yeah people who don't open up in
real life it's really hard to get them
to open up it's not like a switch
you know you get it in one time then
it's like a permanent lane
down open highway you know what i mean
i just met a fourth day see i did that
guys life is a highway and i'm gonna
ride it all night long that's my thing
is i keep like several shots on hand in
case i have to reveal personal
information just to psych myself up i
have several shots on hand when i'm on
the highway yeah it's good that's good
yeah it's boring on the road you gotta
you gotta you know spice things up a
little bit and then if you get pulled
over and thrown in jail
you want to take a little bit more shots
because you're gonna be in jail yeah
it's gonna be messed up and press you
should offer the officer a shot for the
ride over yeah you know you should bring
enough you'd be kind enough to bring it
up for everybody it's funny if you take
his gun
take his gun and trade it for a shot
yeah just be like put this in your
holster for later
because i want you to drive us safely to
prison
i will keep your gun
all right guys well i think we covered
this episode from beginning to end neil
degrasse tyson was more utilized than
nick cannon
what more can you say about that in one
scene versus like several episodes
really cool yeah nick can't expect a lot
more from nikken dude rosa should date
neil degrasse tyson now i wonder who's
going to play tom
i know
john leguizamo ja oh yeah that's a great
edward norton uh ryan quanton from true
blood ludacris uh alexander skarsgard
from true blood
uh kevin sorbo stephen moyer from troop
um melanie griffith
um
anna paquin from trueblood
michael douglas
uh
hey
uh
[Music]
how about
the other guy from workaholics there you
go
i didn't have any more true blood cast
members ryan flock what's his name ryan
ryan that who plays the brother ryan
quanton quantum yeah uh dead silence
yeah yeah he's great australian actor
ryan quantum yeah he's hot i love him
he's so good he's so s he's so strong
buff man he's got so many muscles
deborah and wolf from true blood there
he goes oh
she should be rose gold oh what's the
black girl's name uh tara
i don't remember the actress they recast
her from the pilot
no they reshot the pilot with the new
actors or something like that they had a
different actress play tara and then
they recast here good
uh oh
oh i used to know his name no who plays
lafayette damn it lafayette was the best
may he rest in peace he died that actor
is no longer with us yeah i was really
sad because i was looking forward to his
career popping off
and i used to know his name
now i don't know no i don't have it he
played a gay guy he did he played a very
wonderful and amusing and resourceful
gay guy yeah yeah that's right man
best character
yeah guys go watch true blood
all right guys hey let's do a page
michael lyndon you're not swedish
no you are swedish that's right it gets
confused you're not from switzerland
that's what we always have to figure out
so this is the perfect episode for you
hey why don't you comment underneath
this video and tell us just how accurate
all
the swedishms are in this episode
because if anyone would know it's you is
there do you have a sauna in your house
mikhail can we
are you a pervert are you open to an
insane degree with everyone you know i
want to know and if you are i really
want to know i want to know your deepest
darkest secrets michael i want you to
whisper things in my ear i want your
tuperware no matter what you put inside
of it free you're freaky
free foreign freaks forward freak shout
out foreign freaks
we're before it freaks that if your name
is mikhail say hey
anyway you love you buddy and uh he
doesn't understand jokes he's swedish
i'm sure oh that's right a lot of this
was sarcasm which is when you say
something in a funny tone of voice
that's the opposite of it's like the
satire of comments kind of what is it
the cowards lie howard the cowards lie
in all seriousness mikhail please we
love you and uh let us know how accurate
this was oh my god the pens oh what
physics
phys it's not astronomy but still
physics
i remember doing this in school i loved
doing that in school yeah yeah for eight
hours i would do this too whoa it's like
a whoa mono finger what's going on
that's how swedish people greet each
other hey
let's just diddle each other right now
hello nice to meet you oh yes
freak funny
because joking swedish is swedish none
of you are freaks yeah except for macau
[ __ ] pervert
[Music]